[Music]
they took your land don't have an answer
here Safari hood gone wrong
we can only surmise that the evidence
here portrays the portrayal of the death
of whoever the help see now I have
imprinted this all in my brain I can
recreate this to the best of my ability
the body may be gone but we have a dummy
to reenact my assumption stands as thus
dummy Jim here will portray the murdered
beloved dead from a fall maybe was
strangled but his own cord or he was
thrown into the bathtub and then stopped
gone to the shin splintered orb a house
of lovers embrace squeezed too deeply
his orgasmic delight did Paris not sleep
uh and they when he was trying to flee
from eloping gate to try to dissuade the
attacker and that Oh
we can't stay here long we have to keep
moving
hallo save yourself